guck mal ich bin erster in erster line
endlich willkommen zu einer runderen
dezember zusammen mit vier rechtsklick
auf 4
oben über die genau über die welt okay
ich bin drin manager erklärt noch ganz
kurz das sowie einem lauf wie einem lauf
bei call of duty man hat ein holzschwert
und einen bogen und man hat einen pfeil
und der fall dass egal wie lange man den
bogen spannt oder so man trifft den
anderen und der ist halt dann direktor
und wenn man diesen fall verschossen hat
muss man halt das holzschwert nutzen was
ein ganz normales holzschwert ist und
dann bekommt man wieder ein fall richtig
genau aus der cd 10 sekunden race
piloten dann geht's ab hier auf ihren
die leute schlagen die chancen endlich
wahrscheinlich vorher und macht auch
viel spaß direkt dass das problem das
habe ich immer schon gesagt die leute
das instant ihren kampf ja das ist kacke
wenn ich die rechnung optisch oder auch
die leute die halt den finken namen
haben wird jeder selber tötete und der
irgendwie
nicht wenn die ganze zeit verfolgt den
hätte dir einfach okay jetzt muss ich
erstmal designer töten
der macht den die reds sind leute die fh
sind kann man sich einfach macht die
ganze hektik mit dem bogen da passiert
nichts warum muss doch 80 sparen
ja du musst ein bisschen spannend musst
du schon so auch man jetzt letzten block
hätten die auch noch wie die wilde fahrt
was bringt das redstone das wetter ist
ein lebendes wie viel hast du dann noch
hier läuft bei dir auch mit firmen
dieser zweck dass man da was geht ab
luca noch 24 an hilfsmitteln
das dauert ein bisschen man muss ein
bisschen spielen bis man drin ist aber
dann macht spaß da macht der straße
schon tot luca luka er kommt dann
richtig kalt auf dich hab mich ja super
geil geil ich feiere das hat ja danke
freut mich selbst die das gefällt diese
leute also die haben die übelsten fights
manchmal darauf nicht wird die schießen
irgendwie um die ecke und ja ich habe
auch mal ein getöteter hin und ein
anderes hinein wenn du deine leben weg
ist ist natürlich auch so wie ich jetzt
aber ich habe sieben leute getötet das
gar nicht mal zu gut und jetzt kann ich
also glücklich dazu wie du verlierst
oder das hat man vorgehabt mir da bist
du darfst dir ohne die kenne ich die mit
den roten haaren
da hast du bist vorbeigelaufen
jetzt muss aber trotzdem machen und dann
ohne flüssig läuft hier nichts ich sag's
dir das überzeugte auch man ist das
scheiße ich hasse dich modus rhade muss
ein bisschen üben einen freund oder
möbeln wieder eine lobby und dann ging's
ja machen können wir machen läuft okay
wir gehen direkt mal in die hdfc 18
rechts zur seite war wo 18 hier raus
erst mal bist du denn gleich erkennt
wieder machen und an den abkommen ok und
in 18 18
bei mir eine andere ich hasse diese map
ich passe
aber ich finde dich einfach voll
hässlichen richtig scheiße spielen weil
ich immer hängen bleibt und ich mag
keine löcher
wir sind die bambus ich habe ein zwei
kills
lukat ersten weltkriegs zurück
der junge romand geht ab erster in
dieser komischen tabelle ja man in
altamont das gefällt mir ein bisschen
ruhig gewinnen kann das wirklich gut
gibt einfach unten wo ich einfach mal
gar nichts reißen der komplettverkauf
ein laster zusammen auf den anderen
aufgetaucht dass ich mich wieder an du
nicht boxen okay okay nicht boxen klar
erst mal ausrasten erstmal alles
umwerfen
ich bin dann wasser noch dran jetzt
glaube ich ein ab ich dachte dann auch
so ich bin cool und fangen an block zu
hätten aber die noch nicht und jetzt hat
ihn die zwei mal gestorben
nokia noch einmal gestorben bin
eigentlich sexuell du musst einfach mal
in folge zu machen wenn man halt so
ungefähr voraus leute langlaufen weiße
das ist das was ich richtig cool man
muss einfach so die flugbahnen die
deloitte bahn mit kuchen
ich bin raus das peinlich nur mit fünf
kills bei ich bin auf jeden fall demba
ba ich bin auf jeden fall der barbar
hier ungeheuer challenge 08 cent was
willst du eigentlich ohne witz wer bist
du
fünfkirchen stärkt ihr schafft das hat
der 18 kills geschafft denke das gibt
sogar leute die am 22 kills in einer
runde gemacht
oder 24 dann bei dem ein gesendet
bekommen die kriegst du warst ja ich
hatte zwei herzen
diese zeit diese miese ich finds geil
ich noch killstreaks einbauen würde das
heißt wenn man zum beispiel so weisen
teil und tötet das den stein chance
bekommt dass wir schon fett oder
goldschnitt nur erstmal das wäre auf
jeden fall michelle span span span
controllers keinen fall hat ein um
geklatscht normal ein richtiges team
ach ja dann würde ich sagen gehen wir
noch mal eine lobby rein und dann gehen
wir direkt ihr 16
okay ich bin drin wie lang fünf sekunden
muss ich das da unten
die level das ich finde das eigentlich
so mithalten
auf jeden fall dass ein alter monokel
oper so hatten wir die menschen kennen
die länder wo es geil das hatten wir
alles schon geil
durch gute freunde lädt einmal alles
hier
ich liebe es wenn leute aber zu langsam
sporn ich liebe das ja wenn ihr so
richtig langsam sport aber vorstellen
und dann hört es die einfach so richtig
lange brauchen um richtig rotz
ekelhaften tut mir leid luca education
ja okay ich würde dich nicht du bist
doch so wenn du mich liebst du nicht
statt aus nein ich bin nicht behindert
ich habe anstatt respawn rück zum ticket
zurück läuft ja cool cooler als auch
voll schlechte ja dies auch von mir und
er ist kommt auch schlecht irgendwie
wissen alles nicht so die scanner kann
natürlich der king das angeht mehr oder
weniger gar nicht wenn hier ist längst
nick noch funktionieren würde wäre das
auf jeden fall richtig cool
ja wenn man werden wenn man sich
wirklich so verkleiden könnten sogar mir
echt gut weil im knie stecken was du
abenteurer gut er ist aber jetzt einfach
weg fixed a 4 grad einfach einfach da
bin ich jetzt mit radieren nicht ab 22
ich habe schon mehr gilt
ja das dauert ein bisschen zum updaten
irgendwie auf das ist auch so dass
einfach mal deine teenies abgezogen wenn
er kommt ein halbes war gerade bei mir
und kommt mit dem holzschwert in der typ
hat noch ein leben muss die ganze zeit
an dem knabbern da kommt der inbox man
das war's
diese zeit eine miese zeiten da ich
diese afag komplett oder nicht genau was
passiert du einfach mal alles räumen
alles abräumen alles abgeht 12 12 kiez
oder bleib hier einfach stehen auch gut
bleibt hier verstehen hier stellte ich
hier bin und versteckte ich guck mir zu
einfach so viel du einfach so als wärst
du als fester teil der map okay bin ich
ja auch nicht mal so richtig rasieren
war so von hinten so weit so schön das
arschloch rück von gegen den strich
gegen den strich rasieren oder das finde
ich ziemlich cool macht am meisten spaß
da sind leute die sich gerade jetzt da
oben jemand bei der spanish castle das
wenige der geht ab bei dem läuft sven
ist am sprint auf jeden fall hier hinter
dieser typ hinter dir der herr graf 3
der brauchte man übung zum spawnen ich
danke mich eben dreimal neben dem und
habe einfach direkt geschossenen
geschossen / ak hat man auch im bereich
web portal sondern die ronja stockt uns
sehr war ich war ich in keiner mehr
richtig richtig gut läuft läuft auf
jeden fall mal sprintet und wäre sie
alles hinter dir
anfassen ist ja nix
das muss auch so sein weil ja nicht
getötet ich bin auf jeden fall bestzeit
ich fang oder andere neue holzschwert
dann so meinen sie seien
ich baue meine neben dem teppich aber
dreimal in folge hintereinander getötet
manchmal bei mir werden bei mir auch
schläge einfach nicht angenommen dass
von ranzig schlag so und nichts mit 14
jahren genommen
wir sind wir die ganzen leute die so
hassel nehme ich eben nicht abruft haben
jetzt kommt also klar ich habe noch ein
leben hat danach einfach mal ein kill
gemacht der 2 ich bin jetzt schon dauern
weil ich einfach film erinnert auch mehr
glück als verstand dreimal direkt
nebeneinander passiert am ehesten ein
kind wenn hier oben kämpft dann auf den
spot wartet dann kannst du dies bond
retten kannst du so machen wie der typ
nicht eben diallo tricks genau immer
weiter an alf ist wenn es vorn und
kämpfst du einfach ein bisschen rum muss
gucken dass wir unten keiner kommt noch
die kommt von unten hoch kommen die
können die leitung ja leiter dass die
rollos jetzt aus der luft so
charakterlos
ja ich fühle mich jetzt gerade mal jetzt
muss noch ein pfeil haben fixieren und
dann in ihren kopf ein
das darf man nur zufrieden sein leben
habe ich noch gesehen wie geflogen ist
ja erst gerade seitwärts geflogen
möchten da los freue mich auch was haben
die tests aber ein von denen auch ein
jammern wird sie nach unten gebogen ich
vergesse immer kein bock auf eine runde
pac-man ok 1 1 ich gehen 1 1 1 1
gewinnen wir
ich bin gut ich dachte ich schaffe ich
mehr daran zu gehen kommt bestimmt
ob der busfahrer ist eine anerkannte
weggekickt
das ist nicht fair der tat hatte der
mann
es gibt aber leute dem übel schnellen
drehen sich um richtig krasser reden ich
versuche so zu ziehen und dann sterbe
ich muss nicht so lange zähne darfst du
musst einfach mal auf glück hoffen
ich hab dann getötet 80 distanz für den
neuen da kannst du direkt dann er vor
zwölf wieder hinter mir war es laufen
wir einfach instant alle hinterher
konnte ich bin schon tot
hab noch ein leben ich hab noch ein
leben das werde ich jetzt lasst euch
nicht selber umbringen es geht um junge
glauben packen irgendwie macht mir das
spaß obwohl lassen
nein das ist kein bock aber wenn man
nicht nicht so kennen würde dann wäre
noch besser so jetzt bin ich auch
12 10 668 the [ __ ] und das ist jetzt
schon grad losgegangen egal ich mache
einfach jolo runde ich mache übels auf
dem blue alleine durch guckt er zurecht
dazu bin ich drin
der erntestart ding direkt wieder tut ja
ich kann dir noch mal zu gucken ich
glaube wir müssen im hauptspiel
mittleres und kannst du nicht mal zu
gucken
mehr geht nicht ich kann nicht rein da
die runde irgendwie noch die braucht
irgendein reiche kunden können die das
lesegut besuchten das einfach mal den
ganzen tag ich sag's dir
es sind ferien viele kinder wollten
schon immer mal robin hood spielen und
jetzt rasch die einfach mal aus ich
komme da nicht rein das geht nicht
mies arbeiten sich auf jeden fall cooler
spielmodus also da muss man auch mal
sagen gut gemacht vom box oder wäre ich
weiß gar nicht wer programmiert dass
beide boxer keine ahnung ich hab' ich
hab kein vorne auf jeden fall ist gut
durchdacht aber dass fans
ich könnte mich verbreiten können dass
technik dann wäre alles optimal aber es
funktioniert also ich kriege ich hin
gleich geht es bei dir vielleicht liegt
nur man kann aber glaube ich eher nicht
glaubt tatsächlich dass es nicht
funktioniert so jetzt könnt ihr zu
gucken sie schon bei dir läuft gerade
richtig
bei mir läuft gerade so viele kills und
so fünf hinter dir
nein in der luft guckt das meine ich
drei leute stehen im kreis um weil dann
darum ja so an als würde doch gut zu
nehmen und dann gehen sie auf dich ist
auch so man lernt ja das bringt
angeblich mehr punkte wenn man das ist
das spiel ist einfach neuland für mich
der dark alex für zu töten
doch nicht geklappt tod des wegen mordes
egal ob punkte dann für jeden zweck
punkte und genau man kriegt auch hier
trocken so ich glaube die tories kann
man hier später auch einlösen also man
kriegt hier gibt extra dezember punkte
und diese tokens kann man hier auch noch
bei wänden irgendwie froh wenn wir
reingehen auch noch eine runde ist
gepackt
5 wenn ihr eventuell mehr folgen wolle
im lauf wohl ändern könnte auch einfach
daumen hoch geben oder das halten
schreiben wie ihr wollt entscheidet oder
bayrisch natürlich auch geben immer
dieselben leute wollen glaube ich alle
abfahrten sie komisch
ronja dabei eine runde geht noch top die
wette gilt ja ob die fette grill
hamilton ich weiß ja bestimmt nicht
wieder raus will sich in hätte sich raus
aus den tüten oder wie will ich noch
nicht reingucken
ich drehe mich auch immer direkt jetzt
um wenn ich bin zweiter junger was geht
bei mir ab ich bin vierter guck mal ich
bin erster in erster instanz war das von
mir bestimmt noch ein anderer spieler
abgeprallten hat man wenn ja war extrem
amrum hatten jetzt gerade auch immer
noch ich spiele bei 311 ps
sehr geil geil geil alles hart gespart
wird
alles also soweit nichts jetzt ich bin
jetzt einfach okay ist es fängt sich
langsam wieder so jetzt geht's wieder
einigermaßen alltags wieder das
natürlich geil jetzt gerade ganzheit das
ist natürlich scheiße bei seiner guten
pc das ist irgendwie bezahlen dass sich
das imwf raps oder habe ich kein
sprecher mehr oder ist er heiß server
manchmal aber bei mir ist extrem krassen
das ist das hab ich dass das was willst
du hier vormittag alter noch machen
ausnutzen
das ist natürlich nicht mehr immer so
eine sekunde nicht
ich bin richtig coole tricks helfen
dem pc teile zu braucht eine neue
grafikkarte am netzteil frau alles
selber machen ganz komplett zu spam in
irgendwelchen pc westen
das können wir nicht so per post alles
so zugeschickt bekomme einfach einfach
so tost oder sowas auch wieso
funktioniert in der vergeblich habe
genau auf den drauf geschlossen dass ich
den ball irgendwie teilweise tust es
nicht hey ich bin noch immer dritter
commission tot sind
da denkt so einer jesus freaks die
machen und ich hab jetzt wichtig sie
geben uns einfach mal ne miese montage
machen hier raus wanted hinter hinter
die region zu befrieden der befrieden
täterin die will aufgeben dass ronja
guckt da die mit dem geld das für mich
schon hinter die hänge brust und dass
tito der ist richtig
ich hab den punkt gespielt rekord anja
simon packt das teams mit lex mit lex
winkelt mit lex wanderwegen next
gestorben
in diesem leben gehe ich gerade aber
echt voll ab dass das gerade ein
bisschen aus dass sie schon wieder die
tut nichts ich gehe gerade an so
schlecht da war's mit mit wollen aber
wie gesagt gibt einen daumen hoch wenn
ihr wollt und dann das war's mit region
eame steht wie immer in die kommentare
in den kommentaren schreibt dann in die
beschreibung
ja gut an dem uns beim nächsten